can we just like stay up here all day it  is so crazy down there  finally some privacy it is so crazy down  there  tickets on sale now dude  catch  on sale now dude tickets on sale now  dude  exclusively in movie theaters do you  know peter parker who's spider-man yes  is that him no  can you please explain what is going on  after i shut that spell down we started  getting visitors from every universe  multiverse is real  i need you to capture them before they  destroy the fabric of reality i'm gonna  need some help  you guys ready let's catch some  multiverse men  spider-man your way home what was your  name again dr otto octavius  seriously what's your actual name  hello peter do i know you we started  getting some visitors from every  universe this is all my fault  i promise i'll fix this  we're gonna get through this  and we're gonna get through it together  you